[Music]
if we look back on the sphere where
spiritual reality first made its
appearance we find that the notion
involved was that the utterance of
individuality is that which is both in
and for itself but the shape which
immediately expressed this notion was
the honest consciousness which busied
itself with the abstract thing itself
this thing itself was there a predicate
but it is in conscience that it is for
the first time a subject which has made
explicit all the moments of
consciousness within it and for which
all these moments substantiality and
general external existence and the
essential nature of thought are
contained in this certainty of itself
the thing itself has substantiality in
general in the ethical sphere external
existence in culture the self knowing
essentiality of thought in morality and
in conscience it is the subject that
knows these moments within it well the
honest consciousness always sees is
merely the empty thing itself conscience
on the other hand wins the thing in its
fullness a fullness given to it by
conscience itself conscience is this
power because it knows the moments of
consciousness as moments dominating them
as their negative essence
in paragraph 641 Hegel is pausing for a
moment to show us or rather to explain
to us the transition that is taking
place here in the morality section and
specifically in this this last part of
the morality section which has to do
with conscience and then if you've
looked at the title of this you notice
that we're also going to have you know
the beautiful soul
evil and its forgiveness we haven't
gotten to that content yet and there's
there's really no hint at this point I
think that you can see about where those
are going to arise but in the next few
paragraphs we're going to see the
beginnings of this and I guess you could
say you know the the dynamics that we've
charted out in the earlier part of this
this last section of the spirit portion
of the work you know on the back and
forth between duty and individual and
and universal you can see some of that
going on but here were again like I said
taking a moment to sort of consolidate
things and you notice that Hegel is
going to tell us something about the
previous sections of this this entire
spirit portion of the work the largest
portion he's going to talk about what's
going on in the ethical sphere the very
first part you know where we're dealing
with a you could call it culture if you
want although he's going to use it
different he's going to talk about
culture later on we would call it
culture and an anthropological sense or
sociological sense where it's something
that we have as a background and we're
working our way out through it and then
we have the culture section right and
that has to do with spirit that has
become alienated from itself so it's not
culture in the same sense necessarily as
that which an ethnographer looking at a
you know group might necessarily
describe it's rather culture is the
possibility standing apart from the
ethical substance or the the mores that
were reused to and then finally we get
into the morality
chené right where spirit is is both
alienated and reconciling itself with
itself and you know whenever we have
these big generalities like we're gonna
jump into in just a second about spirit
you know
Geist we should remind ourselves that
the way in which spirit moves forward
for Hegel in the way in which spirit
manifests itself is not only on the sort
of grand scheme big picture sort of
scale it has to happen in terms of
individuals who are related to each
other in their their actions their
passions their you know assumptions that
they have coming to them from what we
typically call culture or their
standpoint in history so that's going to
be an important thing to keep in mind
here we're talking about a particular we
could say generic individual that we're
going to get to in just a moment
Hegel begins this passage by talking
about the sphere where spiritual
spiritual reality first enters and he
says if we look back on that sphere
where spiritual reality here its first
made its appearance ein Clayton right is
the the verb so it literally steps in or
enters or you know shows up is another
way of saying it now what's what's kind
of interesting here from a lexical
perspective you know very often in
translating Hegel into English we will
use the term reality and that's quite
often a translation of the term via
click cut which can also be actuality
here Hegel is not using that term he's
actually using the cognate of English
reality right reality test and so it's
not the same thing as just actuality
there's something a bit more involved
here what is that well we're gonna see
in just a moment so the the sphere where
this first enters in the spirit section
of the work what's going on there he
says we find that the notion or concept
that the grief involved was what
that the utterance or the expression the
expression of individuality
individuality tete is that which is both
in and for itself and here you know I've
got sort of an equal sign right there an
equivalent zyre right that these things
are the the same or that they equal to
each other and here you know it is
something in and for itself but Hegel is
expressing it a little bit differently
again in the the German das on Andrew
seek write that which is in and for
itself something that sort of stands out
by having that quality so that's all
very good right we've we've just you
know been seeking over and over again
for that which is in and for itself this
this Hegelian play between the in the in
itself the for itself also the for
another right we're always trying to
bring them together in a unity and
they're sort of like you know magnets
will ever try to push together they
repulse each other after a while the
closer we get them here now we have a
shift so Hegel says how does this take
place this occurs through what he calls
the shape which immediately expressed
this notion not the only shape possible
right definitely not in the culture
section or the morality section but the
shape in which this expressed itself was
the honest consciousness the air leak
above would sign you could also say the
noble consciousness and we saw that play
itself out in culture where it turned
out that the noble and the base
consciousness were indeed not exactly
the same but interchangeable the noble
consciousness didn't actually measure up
to its own ideals the base consciousness
was what pushed the dialectic forward we
also saw this in the interplay in the
you know the ethical portion early on in
the work dealing with the two laws the
law of the society and the law of the
family or the law of the gods
and the people who stand for them
sometimes you know when we had an
advancement of spirit it's because
somebody you might say instead of just
calling it the honest consciousness
let's call it the fully committed
consciousness the consciousness that
engages itself with some sort of idea or
ideal which is at the same time a
reality of veer cleek Heights and it
tries to conform itself to that
so Antigone trying to bury her brother
is you know a prime example of this as
is her uncle Creon trying to stand for
the city or the you know the nave and
the noble in the interplay and culture
between the honest or the the noble and
the the base consciousness right the
struggle between state power and wealth
it's not individuals who like hedge
their bets and you know just only commit
a little bit that advance the historical
dialectic it's the ones who really throw
themselves into being a certain kind of
thing and they do that on the basis of
thinking that what they're doing is best
is is the right thing for them and
thereby perhaps also the right thing for
others or at least spot to be respected
by others and then they discover of
course that things aren't exactly what
they seem they don't quite measure up to
what they believed and then it's time to
move on again in the dialectic right so
the honest consciousness what does the
honest consciousness doing and here
Hegel brings in another term that he's
been using quite a lot the Jacques ELPS
right and Miller is translating it as
the abstract thing itself not a bad
translation at this point there's other
places within the text where we would
want to translate it differently I've
proposed many times calling it the
project with a sort of capital T capital
P what it is that the person is
attempting to do the thing itself the
thing in itself could be something
epistemological that we're trying to
track down or something metaphysical
actually it is always metaphysis
because it's being accorded a sort of
reality or Bazin right essence an
importance but it's also something
ethical people orient their theoretical
work and they orient definitely
everything else around practical desires
necessities and Hagel is incredibly
attuned to that if you've read through
the earlier parts of the phenomenology
so in trying to figure out what the
abstract thing in itself really is for
example what Duty really commands of me
I am engaging as the honest
consciousness in something that is going
to transform me in finding out what that
that abstract thing itself is and he
talks about the the honest consciousness
busying itself with the abstract thing
itself and there he says it was a
predicate now you might say what's all
this business about predicates and
subject and here Hegel is being a little
bit metaphorical you know is the thing
itself literally a predicate what is a
predicate a predicate is what I'm about
to give you one a predicate is something
said of something else that is something
said of something else is me predicating
that language that string of words of
the subject the term predicate I just
explained it to you by displaying you
know subject Kopila predicate ironically
in this case the predicate was subject
right and the other string of words was
the predicate does Hegel mean that the
thing itself is predicate in that sense
not exactly Hegel likes to use this
language of subject and predicate and
play off of it and play with it in a lot
of different ways and here he is
exhibiting that that sort of play the
predicate would be something that is
dependent upon the subject that's an
important part of it and one of the
things
you're gonna see Hegel always trying to
do is see if we can't get the predicate
to somehow be a subject itself that
happens here so how does this happen
well he talks about what's going on in
this thing itself he says the thing
itself is a predicate it's in conscience
that it is for the first time a subject
how because it has made explicit all the
moments of consciousness within it and
for which all these moments
what are these moments substantiality in
general substantiality itself right
external existence or external being and
self knowing essentiality of thoughts a
little bit later he's gonna frame that a
little bit differently but it but it's
still the same general idea we're gonna
come to that we're gonna look at each of
these in turn each of these are moments
or you know I think of them as not quite
parts but interconnected components of
the whole that is the abstract thing
itself and each of these has been
charted out in a previous dialectical
development that Hegel has charted out
and can associate with the different
sections of spirit isn't that convenient
that the work falls into you know a
structure like that so we have the
ethical sphere we have culture and we
have morality not the entire morality
section but the morality section up to
this point with the two previous sub
sections because conscience is going to
be doing something different it is
providing a subjectivity to this this
otherwise predicate of the thing itself
so he says the thing itself has
substantiality in general in the ethical
sphere substantiality at uber helped
write substantiality as such you could
say it also has external existence
external existence boisterous design
design being there and you know how does
it have external existence well there's
this estrangement it is
outside of itself it you know the thing
itself finds that it doesn't have its
meaning in itself but rather in its
other and then we have the self-knowing
essentiality of thought phase and as
denken x' right and he'll he'll
elaborate a little bit on that he says
that it's in the self knowing
essentiality of thought is in morality
but then it's in conscience this very
last section and which is not just a
section in the book but it's supposed to
be charting out a development of the
human being it is in conscience that it
becomes the subject that knows these
moments within it these moments don't
know themselves adequately they did work
themselves out and as you know actually
human beings they did have their own
seeming substantiality and seeming
subjectivity actually not seeming
subjectivity they had subjectivity
locally that appeared to be global you
could say now we have a subject who
actually is global in that sense so he
goes on and he says while the honest
consciousness always sees it sees is
merely the empty thing itself and he
uses the word lares there avoid there's
a void there within it a privation a not
quite being you know filled in
conscience
it actually graphs he says the thing in
its fullness the thing the abstract
thing becomes concrete a fullness given
to it by conscience itself now here's
the last part of it conscience is this
power because it knows the moments of
consciousness as moments dominating them
as their negative essence it does not
treat any single one of these as if it's
more than it is it says you are
components within a larger system or
structure and the binding is is the
conscience and you notice he talks about
conscience is negative here so
conscience itself does not yet have a
positivity
of itself which it arguably does have in
some of the shapes that we're going to
look at in a few paragraphs later
when conscience is considered in
relation to the single determinations of
the antithesis manifest in action and
its awareness of the nature of those
determinations its relation to the
actual case in which it has to act is in
the first instance that of knower
insofar as this knowing has in at the
moment of universality conscientious
action requires that the actual case
before it should be viewed
unrestrictedly in all its bearings and
therefore that all the circumstances of
the case should be accurately known and
taken into consideration but this
knowing since it knows the universality
as a moment is at the same time aware
that it does not know all the
circumstances or in other words that it
does not act conscientiously the
genuinely universal and pure relation of
knowing would be a relation to something
not containing an antithesis a relation
to itself but action in virtue of the
antithesis it essentially contains is
related to a negative of consciousness
to a reality possessing intrinsic being
contrasted with the simplicity of pure
consciousness with the absolute other or
implicit manifold Ness this reality is a
plurality of circumstances which breaks
up and spreads out endlessly in all
directions backwards into their
conditions sideways into their
connections forward into their
consequences the conscientious mind is
aware of this nature of the thing and of
its relation to it and knows that in the
case in which it acts it does not
possess that full acquaintance with all
the attendant circumstances which is
required and then it's pretense of
conscientiously weighing all the
circumstances is vain however this
acquaintance with and weighing of all
the circumstances are not altogether
lacking but they exist only as a moment
as something which is only for others
and this incomplete knowledge is held by
the conscientious mind to be sufficient
and complete because it is its own
knowledge
in paragraph 642 we find that there is
something going on with conscience that
results in when it moves away from being
a sort of pure knowing and engages in
action which it has to do it becomes
less conscientious or even sufficiently
unconscious that it's very status as
conscience gets called into question as
we're going to see a little bit later on
right now Hegel is just sort of setting
out the problematic and some of the
elements of this are not unfamiliar to
those who have traversed the
phenomenology up to this point
especially some of the antithesis that
are involved in action or comportment
you might say as another way to
translate honden you know a sort of
continual way of behaving not just a
single act necessarily but a set of
actions that are meaningful and
committed
so there is an antithesis in action and
that it's always got to be conditioned
by the circumstances here Hegel's
framing it in terms of knowledge and in
terms of practical knowledge and in
terms of the kind of practical knowledge
that is give this in or or conscience
right which is supposed to be you know
getting us to a new stage of the
dialectic it's supposed to be universal
this is supposed to be the answer to a
lot of our questions up until this point
so he says when we're considering
conscience in relation to single
determinations of the antithesis the
Gaghan thoughts manifest in action and
it's awareness of the nature of these
determinations the the ways in which
action is actually determined its
relation to the the actual case in
German the vehicle a kite does follow so
follows a case the way something is
right it's really a cognate to the Latin
kasam that we we have four uppercase
your clear-cut actuality reality what
what the thing is so here we're talking
not just about the case itself but what
happens to be the case what is the case
we have to act never in a pure you know
sort of abstract never-never-land the
realm of theory maybe a lot of what we
do in ethics class this is like that you
know we have these abstract trolley
problems you never actually get put into
a trolley problem you always get put
into something that's a lot Messier and
not quite so clean in its contours and
there's epistemological problems and
well do I actually know all of the
conditions involved in this case and the
answer is usually I don't know if I do
or not that's not just know I don't know
everything that's involved we are this
is a little bit of a side topic we are
often ignorant of the level or the range
of the ignorance that we are suffering
under but we we do if we're being honest
with ourselves know that we don't know
everything
so the knower is dealing with an actual
case and they're trying to act in
relation to the actual case so says the
the way in which conscious is
understanding itself is that of nowhere
now we're gonna look at that we're going
to analyze this conception do I actually
know enough
he says insofar as this knowing has in
at the moment of universality insofar as
somebody who's acting in good conscience
we're not just supposed to be like
acting according to our whims we're
supposed to be doing something Universal
not necessarily with conscient
universality where we have to will at
the same time it can be a universal law
of nature covering everybody you know
etc etc but there is a sort of
universality there if I say I should do
things this way somebody else can ask me
well why the hell did you do it that way
and I should give them answers and they
say oh yeah I should have done the same
thing myself in those circumstances not
oh man you are totally off-base I would
have done it differently and here's
where the universal is so he goes on and
he says
conscientious action right
[Music]
action that is that is being done in
accordance with conscience requires that
the actual case before it should be
viewed unrestrictedly literally without
you know being hemmed in one unshrunk
though right
not being sort of artificially
restricted you might say are treated
reduction mystically right we should
look at it in all the circumstances of
the case should be accurately known and
taken into consideration so you know if
we've got some sort of judicial action
that we have to take we should find out
not just you know did that person do
that sort of thing and read the police
report and maybe call a few witnesses we
should look into it and see what exactly
was going on what's the background of
these people you know what were the
circumstances that were happening then
we can come to a fully informed decision
or if we're deciding about our own you
know career path we should do the
research and figure out would this
actually be the right thing for me to do
is it is the right thing in terms of
like it's going to be financially
beneficial to me or is it the right
thing in terms of I'm going to be
helping other people that otherwise
wouldn't be helped by the use of my
talents and capacities or you know we
could think of all sorts of other
circumstances we should take in the
totality of everything so that we can
act conscientiously right in accordance
with conscience does not mean just
following a rule or listening to a vague
voice in your head it means doing your
due diligence here's where it gets tough
though right
we can't always do that can we
especially when we have to act action by
its very nature is not just a matter of
dealing with particulars it's a matter
of never having fully enough time to
investigate everything so he says this
knowing the knowing of conscience
because it knows universality as a
moment is aware it does not know all the
circumstances
or in other words that it does not act
conscientiously now as Hegel saying oh I
see everyone's full of it
nobody's conscientious he's not saying
that he's not saying by the way that
this automatically derails the ethical
project and nobody can ever live up to
conscience he's just saying if you're
really conscientious you are going
beyond these you might say superficially
conscientious person because you realize
that you're not being fully
conscientious right you're not taking
account of everything because you don't
have that as a possibility and so
there's a certain unconsciousness in the
heart of being conscientious in terms of
action so he goes on and he says the
universal and pure relation of knowing
would be a relation to something and
here's where the text gets a little bit
tricky I understand why Miller's
translating it the way he is but there's
two uses of the word antithesis
following upon each other in this this
passage and they're not exactly the same
term but they are closely connected so
he talks let me actually just read the
passage to you and then we'll talk about
how these are slightly different but
connected he says the genuine the
universal pure relation of knowing would
be a relation to something not
containing and antithesis a relation to
itself but action in virtue of the
antithesis it essentially contains is
related to a negative of consciousness
to a reality possessing intrinsic being
so action as we've seen we've talked
about this plenty in previous passages
in not just the spirit section but also
in the reason section as well and in the
self consciousness section quite frankly
action involves an antithesis
Gagen Zots things being opposed to each
other it has its antithesis in itself he
says so every time that you act there's
there's something else that's opposed to
it it's not antithesis in the sense of
the you know old Hegelian 3-step of
thesis antithesis synthesis put that
sort of stuff out of your head
because that's not what's happening here
with the reference to antithesis instead
when you act the act never turns out to
be exactly what you intended because
it's in a matter it's in relation to an
object that itself kind of muna might
say pushes back presents some obstacle
that otherwise you wouldn't act now the
first reference to antithesis here
saying that there is no antithesis in
this is I nicked and Gagan Gazette's
this so you notice there's a similarity
right Gagen gazettes does Gagan Zots
right those are those are connected one
is a adjective one is a noun so you
might say I not antitheses in relation
to the other the end Gagan gazettes does
right this is sort of an intensification
and it's saying there isn't this this
you know opposition going on within the
the knowing the pure knowing but the
knowing that we're doing when we're
actually acting in a real case is
different than what we do in
idealizations or even you might say idle
conversations about what we ought to do
so he goes on and he says the action
right is is related to a negative of
consciousness a reality possessing
intrinsic being that's the the actual
case and the objects that were acting on
it's also the things within ourselves
that we don't fully understand - and he
goes on he says contrasted with the
simplicity of pure consciousness with
the absolute other or implicit manifold
this you know you might say multiplicity
in a certain sense this reality this is
this actual case that we're dealing with
is as he says a plurality of
circumstances a genuine multiplicity a
feel height to their own agenda you know
the room standard are the things that
are all surrounding the object or the
case or something like that
a few height a multiplicity of many
necessities
how many are in this this feel height
this this plurality well way too many to
count an almost infinity
you can't specify it ahead of time you
could specify it in general but then you
get to the case and it turns out that
some parts are important in other parts
aren't so he says this reality is a
plurality of circumstances and here's a
beautiful spatial metaphor also a
temporal metaphor which breaks up and
spreads out endlessly in all directions
backwards into their conditions but
England right the things that help to
produce the situation that you're in
sideways into their connections namin he
says you're an Navin Ananda right how
they're not just connected he doesn't
say but zu ihnen right
so Miller's translation here's a little
bit you know
wonky how they're arranged in in
relation to each other we're like you
see this and then you're like oh that
leads to this that leads to this this is
behind this this is behind this forwards
into their consequences folding the
things literally that follow from them
so we have here sort of a nexus every
single case that we're dealing with that
we like to look at as an abstract thing
with nice you know border walls is
actually connected with everything else
and this is the nature of human action
Hegel is just somebody who's really
attuned to to seeing this and that is
part of what infects conscience which
would like everything to be nice and
clean and meet with this unconsciousness
within itself so he says the
conscientious mind is aware of this and
it knows that in the case in which it
acts it does not possess that full
acquaintance with all these attendant
circumstances which is required why not
because it's not God right you'd have to
like know everything in order to be
totally acquainted with it and he says
that it's pretense of conscientiously
weighing all circumstances is in vain
now is this a
for despair he says the acquaintance
with and weighing of all the
circumstances are not altogether lacking
but they exist only as a moment as
something which is only for others isn't
that an interesting twist it's how we
justify things not just to ourselves but
to those others who are seeking
recognition from why did you behave this
way why did you do this action this way
well because the case had these certain
circumstances and I could see that these
are going to be the consequences and
these are the reasons why I came up and
then somebody can say well did you did
you also check this no I didn't check
that we're being held accountable to
others in this right the measure of our
own conscientiousness is not solely our
own feeling about it or the stories that
we tell us but also that of others who
we don't control right so he says they
are something which is only for others
and this incomplete knowledge is held by
the conscientious mind to be sufficient
and complete because it is its own
knowledge this is the danger of
conscience at this point the person
who's conscientious might say well I
don't have to be fully accountable to
others it's good enough that I can
satisfy my own conscience now we'll see
how far that goes as we move into the
next paragraphs
you